miss Tana hello you were supposed to
co-host this press conference yeah what
happened
I'm our time when you just got really up
I thought I had to be here at 10:00 a.m.
and make up art it's just a bunch of
crazy stuff but I decided I still want
to just like show up and support and
like show face and like you know cheer
him on and like all that kind of stuff
you know so yeah I love that because you
guys did just announce your break not
really break up but a break it's nice to
see that you're still friends working
through this what sparked the break
though and like just because you take a
break does that mean of the day after
you look I don't support you at all
anymore like of course I want to be here
to cheer him on yeah I don't know I
think Jake really fell in love with
boxing and it became kind of his whole
entire world and like I got really busy
and we both were just at a place where
it was like I can barely fit you into my
life coming from both ends you know and
it's like sometimes when you love
someone so much it's so much easier to
to let them go through a time where they
can't love you the way that they might
want to or the way you might want them
to you know so um I feel like right now
we're just at a point where all we
really have time for to make work right
now is friendship and that's where it
all started and I'd rather I love him
too much to do anything else you know so
it's like yeah I'm Jake's main love main
priority main focus right now is boxing
so I still want to show support and just
be a really good friend to him I asked
him but I'm curious what you're gonna
say is there a chance you guys get back
together I think that questions that
look so ahead in the future like that or
what me up every single time you know
what I mean I'm making impulsive
decisions based on what I think is gonna
happen in the future but in reality none
of us know what is gonna happen in the
future yeah and if you're so busy living
in the future with all of that anxiety
when you could be living in the present
like what you're doing no offense I'm
just saying so it's like for me to sit
here every day and be like are we gonna
get back together it is like that'd be
so toxic for my mental state so it's
more so like I'm taking it day-by-day
and like I love him I always will love
him and if it's meant to be it will be
you know what I mean but if it's not
then it's like I'm not gonna try to
force something that isn't there for the
both of us you know what you are him
that initiated the break-up or was that
even
no I don't think it was like that at all
I think it's more so that we both just I
think there was a moment where we both
just kind of noticed that things weren't
as easy as they used to be I guess you
know what I mean seeing each other and
being around each other making time to
do you know as and as our interest
divided you know I'm still in love with
YouTube and making videos like we were
and all that kind of stuff and he's
falling in love with boxing and like
what I you know what I mean and it's
like I never want to be in a position
with someone I love so much where I'm
forcing a fake reality to try to like
keep that you know what I mean and I
think that because Jake and I are always
so on the same page it was like we
didn't even have to talk people can just
look at each other and know this wasn't
the right time to try to nurture
something that I couldn't be there in
that moment you know and it's like we I
would only want to you know be together
at a time where every day is the most
fun day ever like you know like I want
to do it then oh I don't think anybody
really initiated anything I think we're
both just kind of always on the same
page there were a lot of naysayers about
the relationship to begin with saying is
this real is this fake I mean yeah
accidently so though like honestly if I
was a u2 watching I'm not watching me
I'd be like that that is so fake like
Logan today was like did they break up
he kind of made like scoffed at it so
what do you say to those people I think
it's always gonna be like that I mean I
made a video a few I'm like a few weeks
ago probably a week or two ago really
talking about my mental health and like
the love I have for Jake in the way that
I looked at the relationship and at this
point that's realistically all I can do
other than slowly release music over
time or come out with books or whatever
it may be
but I mean like what I'm gonna spend
every day defending myself to every
single person every single internet role
every single everything I understand why
people think it wasn't real and in a lot
of ways it wasn't like what was the
wedding what was all of that but like my
love for Jake is something that's like
like why am I here right now it's
undeniable you know what I mean so it's
like I don't really care anymore you
know I'm trying to open a new chapter of
loving myself and you know helping my
young following watch that growth so
that the young girls that watch me can
learn
themselves sorry that was a lot of time
love the honesty and how candid you
always are and you mentioned your mental
health and you're always very open about
that so I'm just curious how are you
doing
thank you you're so sweet that's so so
nice of you to ask it's crazy that you
say that because it's like I'm working
with one of my best friends companies
make sure your friends are okay to kind
of start an entire campaign and like
charity stuff charity related stuff in
2020 and obviously the everything behind
make sure your friends are okay is just
starting a conversation with someone you
know or don't know about asking if
you're okay and normalizing the stigma
but not being you know what I mean look
of it being easy to check on your
friends so it's like right now I know
that I'm you know I'm going through it
it's really hard to do anything like a a
breakup you know in the media but also I
signed up for this and also I'm laying
in my bed you know and it's like of
course I wish I could just support Jake
as a friend off camera but Jake is doing
things like this where there are lots of
cameras around so I'm here I'm happy for
him he's still my best friend we're
working on everything kind of 2020 is
gonna be amazing you know it's gonna
take over for usual but yeah you watch a
warrior no you're supposed to eat if my
fans are doing it all for me I swear to
god they've carried me through the last
few months you know so are you looking
to date again soon or will you kind of
take time for yourself it's kind of
funny it would be velocity that because
I'm like you know like I I really just
want to be surrounded by love like my
friends and the like the people that
like I love and I'm passionate about
being around and whatever and taking
time to just learn to love myself and
all that kind of stuff so I'm not I'm
not doing anything I'm just doing me you
know what I mean you never know what
anything holds I'm never gonna write
anything away because obviously I'm Tana
and I'm impulsive I'm impulsive as yeah
don't know what you learn about yourself
throughout this relationship and the
break-up that's a great question I
learned so many things that I've written
a book about it um but I feel like
throughout this relationship I really
learned how to reach my full potential
and like really unlock to new levels of
my passion
unlike business learned so much as a
business person in one year and also
obviously just like learned that so much
about love and like that you know I
talked a lot about that in my mental
health video as well but to keep it
concise that it's very important to love
yourself and all of that kind of stuff
I feel like I learned that I don't want
to do everything in the media and the
fame isn't all it's cracked up to be so
many things I feel like I learned more
in 2019 than I ever have in my entire
life like I aged like a decade mentally
this year if you are constantly in the
headlines I mean if it wasn't Jake it
was Noah Cyrus I mean how do you handle
seeing so much news come out of about
you all the time it was weird when I
started to notice that it wasn't just
like because I've been used to it for
awhile from like Bella and just other
stuff like that you know um Tanika and
obviously bad things as well I don't
want to sit here and sound like getting
like stuck I've been bragging um I've
been used to it but when it got to a
point where it was like Tana mojo eats
donut at cafe in New York City like Tana
mojo outfit sorry like when it literally
just became everything I do I remember
noticing this drastic like change in my
life and it was really weird and having
to kind of adapt to that overnight it's
definitely something that takes a toll
on you mentally another thing I'm
writing about I just sound like I'm
plugging my book so much I'm so sorry
hopefully in early 2020 but yeah I don't
know it's it's crazy I wouldn't trade it
for anything you know cuz it's like I
made those youtube videos to hopefully
make one person smile every single day
and that's so what I'm passionate about
and will always want to do but the the
new level of press is for sure insane
yeah yeah it sounds crazy sorry another
long response from Dennis I love that
though this is why we like you because
you are so honest and I know I keep
saying that but I mean it I will say
Jake said that you guys are gonna have a
divorce party ha ha
honestly we probably will I know that
that sounds like an insane confirmation
right now like oh my gosh Jake
getting a divorce party that's gonna go
wrong I don't mean for it to be like
that it's more so just that like as hurt
as I am and as much as like we're like
you know take separating taking a break
for a second Jake and I still I'm very
fortunate to be able to still look at
Jake and I suppose be so grateful for
the entire experience and what it taught
us so like for us we've and just as much
as the wedding it wasn't on paper it was
a celebration of love we want to have a
celebration of like you know like this
amazing year where we both changed each
other's lives you know so we just kind
of started making jokes about like a
divorce party and we kind of might want
to do with all of our friends but we
realize we're insane for that uh-huh I
don't know that's yeah AET if that
happened one oh my god I'm scared I'm
scared
you guys just me crying how do you have
you shed tears over this are you kidding
me you're hurt and you talk about crying
and I'm shocked and the glasses are just
too like hiding to tearing up doing the
press today of course when you have to
go through anything like this with
someone that you love it's it's painful
it's really painful obviously but at the
same time like if it's what's best and
you care about them like you got to go
through it so you know yeah very nice to
show up will you be here will you be in
Miami for the fight who knows stay tuned
[Laughter]
[Music]